se trata de un día muy importante para
la política alemana dos meses después de
las elecciones federales de septiembre
los socialdemócratas los verdes y los
liberales presentaron aquí en berlín su
acuerdo de coalición el documento clave
con el que pretenden gobernar los
próximos cuatro años el documento que
contiene sus principales promesas
promesas como el aumento del salario
mínimo o una gran inversión en las
energías renovables este acuerdo aún
debe ser presentado a los miembros de
los diferentes partidos en conferencias
partidistas por ejemplo pero se espera
que eso sea aprobado sin ningún problema
y que dé vía libre para que el próximo
canciller de alemania sea olaf scholz de
los socialdemócratas el actual
vicecanciller y ministro de finanzas con
lo que también se pondría punto final a
los 16 años de gobierno de la canciller
angela merkel según la información que
ha trascendido aquí en berlín se espera
que olaf scholz sea presentado como
nuevo canciller de alemania ante el
bundestag
la segunda semana de diciembre